okay well liberal cities are pointing a
finger at President Trump for the
growing homeless crisis it comes after
Trump blasted California and New York on
Twitter and said the federal government
might help if the state leaders there
asked for it politely New York City
Mayor Bill DeBlasio responding by saying
this problem ultimately is Donald Trump
has not shown any willingness to give us
the tools we need most especially
section 8 vouchers which allow people
who live in rental housing that's the
single strongest piece we need from
Washington that we're not getting right
now let me play a factor in the Trump
administration many times you've seen
the HUD budget is basically zeroed out
no additional resources to an original
invitees all right well we know
homelessness is directly related to high
unemployment rates and drug use laurens
under the trump administration we have
our lowest unemployment rates and yet
you have liberal mayors and governors
decriminalizing drug use which is what
we're seeing in California so is it
really the Trump administration needs to
do something or is that that the local
lawmakers need to be doing something
this is a local matter and I've been to
all of these local cities covering it
for the channel it's a big epidemic
going to nose town and I'm sorry these
cities were jacked up before Donald
Trump and they're probably going to be
jacked up after them because the city
they won't take matters into their own
hands
he wants section eight I'm sorry I don't
want more Americans on section eight
it's decimated my community many of
those people maintain on section eight
instead of creating an environment where
these people can get good-paying jobs
stop the crime you want them to stay in
poverty I'm sorry that's not a good
answer for men well Murray he makes an
excellent point there that they're
requesting more section eight funding
but really what is the long-term
solution and what is the exit strategy
you can't just put everyone on section
eight no one knows what the long-term
strategy is if there were an easy fix or
an easy answer these cities I have to
believe would be doing those things
because this is a huge problem and is an
impotent and epidemic in some of these
places and it is heartbreaking and so I
I don't know quite frankly I don't know
what the policy answer is I do think HUD
can do more at the federal level what I
just I react so negatively to the REA
president Trump the language he uses to
talk about the homeless problem it
I know we say this a lot about him but
but these are people these are humans
and the way he talks about it and uses
it to go after some of his political
rivals it's not helping solve the
problem and it just feels so heartless
and I know that sounds like a liberal
saying this but but it really is I mean
when you walk around the city your heart
breaks when you see people who can't
manage to find a place to live and I
don't know what the answer is but I
don't think that Donald Trump is
actually trying to solve it I think he's
just trying to use it politically well I
think he has made some measures to solve
the homelessness in the sense of
creating more jobs and making from some
more affordable housing now Tom last
year the liberal 9th Circuit ruled to
restrict the ability of cities to
actually clear homeless encampments and
that is now making businesses leave
these areas I mean that can't be good
for the long-term stability of these
cities obviously not good and that's
what President Trump is doing he's not
being heartless he's teasing mayor's
like Bill DeBlasio who have failed
policies this thing about section 8
housing I mean Lawrence you when most of
America most Americans hear that and
they say what is this guy governing
America's biggest city how do we have
these leaders who have these failed
pulse everyone knows that section 8 talk
is old school it's bad it's failed
that's what it's it doesn't work cycle
of poverty yeah yes you know Emily Marie
mentioned that it's about the federal
government must be doing something but
the federal government is wanting to
make tighter immigration control however
California refutes all of that in fact
in the last year illegal immigrants
caused California 23 billion dollars in
state and local taxes so how can they
say that they need federal help or the
federal government's not doing enough
when they are rejecting what the federal
government is trying to do to for the
homeless crisis right and what I'm
hearing is an apt statement which is
that California and a lot of democratic
run cities and states are there spending
historically they're spending historic
amounts and yet the homelessness
statistics are also historically spiking
so we had governor Newsom right he said
look the investments made during the
Obama administration since 2010 have
resulted in a 50% decrease in
homelessness and veterans now that may
be true but he's parsing
his facts because again the homelessness
however is spiking in that state in
those cities including his his care not
cash campaign that filled in San
Francisco when he was mayor so because
these leaders leaders like de Blasio are
obsessed with kind of touting their own
their own accomplishments they're
failing to see the forest for the trees
the City of Newark is suing de Blasio
right now for his plan to bust the
homeless owner over there creating that
dependency issues that you talked about
and in terms of what you just said Maria
I agree with I think it's it's a war of
compassion which is crippling people on
the left in terms of their approach to
this which is why there's a failure to
account for all of those vectors like
drug addiction and mental illness and
the lake it's not just about you know an
affordable housing it's not just about
units so huge a huge part of the
homelessness are either on drugs
addicted to drugs or mentally ill so if
you're not focusing on those as well the
homeless crisis is a moot point because
you can't just give everyone a job and
think that they're gonna be functioning
members of society it's just not it you
can't just give them free housing and
they're not going to be a functioning
members of society we have to really
come together a multi-faceted approach
and it's not gonna be solved overnight
but I do think that the local
governments just have a lot more that
needs to be done and they need to stop
saying the federal government needs to
take step in or it's Trump's problem
when he's actually is doing some reforms
to try and make it better